Speaker 1: Let's hear from people in the audience
on this slightly early Friday type show, because
the week is a little bit different this week.
We take calls via discord at David Pakman
dot com slash discord.
And we're going to start today with Alex from
California.
Alex, welcome.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David.
Speaker 1: Can you hear me?
I can hear you fine.
Speaker 2: Nice.
So when it comes to, like, elections and how
people vote, it really seems like it comes
down to the economy than anything else.
Like you have things like Roe v Wade or like
gay marriage be overturned.
But if there is like a recession in that same
year, it feels like they'll vote on the recession
and say, oh, Democrats ruined the economy.
Who cares about these, like civil rights issues?
Yeah.
What do you think about that?
Speaker 1: I completely agree.
The perception of how the economy is doing,
even if, number one, people's perception is
wrong.
And number two, it doesn't really have much
to do with the president.
Both are hugely influential in how people
vote.
And this is why things are suddenly looking
much better for Democrats, even though I don't
think it really has much to do with Joe Biden.
There was this blockbuster jobs report in
July.
Wages are up, inflation is down, gas prices
are down, etc..
It has very little to do with Joe Biden, but
it seems to be helping Democrats very much
in terms of the outlook for November.
So, yes, it's the economy, stupid, was the
phrase James Carville came up with.
And it it is more like it is the perception
of the economy, regardless of whether it's
accurate.
Speaker 2: Okay.
So let's say I've been here a lot of like
recession warnings coming up.
They say there's going to be like a recession
in like 2024.
Let's say there is.
Yep.
So is that going to be the determining factor
whether or not like Joe Biden loses the election,
even though like Democrat, the Republican
agenda is like has really awful things like
to like to do or how or what to do.
Speaker 1: So I don't know.
You're saying if there is a recession or you're
saying there won't be one?
Speaker 2: Yeah, no, I'm saying if there is
a recession, that's pretty much a guaranteed
loss for like Joe Biden if he if he decides
to run.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: I think if at the time if I think
if Joe Biden runs for reelection and there
is a very clear recession in September and
October of 2024, I think Biden definitely
loses.
That's so far off.
And remember, people have been predicting
imminent recession since 2015 and it hasn't
really happened.
I mean, you could argue technically we just
were in one because GDP went down very, very
slightly last quarter.
But when you look at every other indicator,
it's really hard to make that case.
But let's wait and see.
I agree with you, though.
If there is really a recession, it's going
to be bad for Joe Biden if he's on the on
the ticket.
Speaker 2: All right.
That's it.
And thank you for taking my call.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Very, very good questions.